[Musique]
derrière ton autre
sourire
[Musique]
c'est
parfois les filles pleurent
[Musique]
je me sens
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand les lumières de la ville seront assez loin
pour voir les étoiles
[Musique]
fais-moi confiance
le temps viendra où nous  devrait être
[Musique]
souvenirs
quand les lumières de la ville sont assez loin
pour voir les étoiles quand
l'obscurité est autour de nous
est une maison salée
[Musique]
souvenirs
et si c'était
[Musique]
paix
maintenant
[  Musique]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
oh
[Musique] à
peu près six histoires
j'ai besoin de leur parler
même si je n'ai rien de spécial
à prouver tu sais que je suis juste
[  Musique]
je peux changer
[Musique]
moi
regarde moi
mais nous sommes des millions de personnes à avoir des doutes
[Musique]
ça vient
c'est
je peux changer
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
[  Musique]
je ne suis pas un chien élevant mon
chien si tu essaies de me défier
toi